boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very excited to be talking about a I an
education we have Brian Todd be joining
us on the show hello hello how are you
thank you so much for coming on very
pumped for this episode thank you for
having me
you're very welcome those who don't know
Brian's background he started his career
at age 16 working for NASA Goddard Space
Flight Center and is now founder and CEO
over her AI which invented a technology
that enables people to learn three to
five times faster than traditional
education you can find the links in the
bio below - O'Hara a i.com as well as
the LinkedIn Twitter Instagram profiles
in hero glass-top org alright Brian
let's start things off by asking you
about who are you tell us about your
journey yeah absolutely so I had a
pretty fascinating one I was born in a
tiny village with no running water and
no electricity now in the south eastern
desert of Iran a tiny village called Zen
Geron my father was part of a tribe of
nomadic Turks called the Qashqai
brilliant people the friendliest people
in the world and so he was one of the
first people in his tribe to go to
university and he came back and ran a
school that under a black tents went
around nomadically across the desert
with the tribe and trained the next
generation of youth from the - my tribe
so fast forward a number of years I was
born and unfortunately we had to well
fortunately and unfortunately had to
flee persecution in Iran during the time
of the Ayatollah and so we escaped
across the border into Turkey where we
lived in abject poverty for two years
while we were waiting for political
asylum here in the United States and
well the reason I said fortunately
before is that even though it was very
difficult I am eight once we moved to
Maryland we had
to one of the best educational systems
in the world and so that was a
fascinating experience I didn't really
understand the culture of the language
so I dove into science and math taught
myself quantum mechanics and
differential equations from a pretty
young age wrote a couple white papers
and eventually got invited to come to
NASA Goddard Space Flight Center in
Maryland to begin working there when I
was 16 so that was a wild experience I
felt like I was a kid in a candy store
every day I would go in and take what's
called an air shower so I worked in the
cleanroom and so for majority of the
time I was there and so it was
fascinating because you go in you take a
it's like basically a shower except to
choose high pressure air at you so you
take it an air shower to take off all
the dust particles from your body you
get into what we affectionately called a
bunny suit which is essentially a big
white plastic suit with transparence
part over your face and so you take a
second air shower to just in case any
particulates got from your clothes to
the outside of the bunny seat so we go
into the clean room and if you don't
know what a clean room is it's
fascinating it's this room the size of
several football fields and on one side
they have a series of fans of all sizes
that shoot air across the room and on
the other side they have your own
massive vacuum air tunnel no kind of air
tools are a little bit different this is
a cleanroom and so what a cleanroom this
is a clean it's a football field yeah
well that's where they put together a
lot of the satellites of shovels and
things like that so it's it's pretty big
and so the opposite side they have these
vacuums that siphon the air so there's
always this kind of wind coming through
and the air gets cycled through a series
of filters that clean the air too I
think if I'm if my memory serves me
correctly I might be off by an order of
magnitude or so but I think one part per
million particles because if you have a
dust particle on a lens or on a mirror
that goes into space well that ruins any
of the data that you collect it corrupts
it so one dust particle can ruin data
that you're collecting
absolutely right yeah because I mean
that's the amount of of light the
amounts of data that you're collecting
from you know thousands of light years
way is just constantly going through the
the lens or the the mayor depending on
what kind so we worked on the
constellation X project and so we were
looking at the the emanations from the
supermassive black hole to Center the
galaxies so you need to have lenses of
very large proportions and then we
realize that if you use parallax you can
point a bunch of satellites at that
point in it magnifies the image
tremendously so it was pretty
fascinating
what a crazy upbringing for you and your
family yeah
anybody fortunate fortunate but also
unfortunate yeah that yet to leave
there's also a just more and more I
think we're gonna end up getting towards
this at the end but there's got to be a
stronger harmony and coherence with
nature and with each other on this
planet moving forward because we get we
got a we got to get over the self
dealing and the corruption and the the
hatred and the war these are these
things are obsoleting and we gotta push
in that direction so well you're
absolutely right I agree completely and
it's obviously caused a lot of pain and
suffering for a lot of people and beyond
that it's also very inefficient right I
mean it's all this wasted effort wasted
resources they said time we said mental
energy that can be used for much more
productive things for moving human
society forward laquer yeah waste of
human potential this type of stuff you
know this became really clear to me when
I had an opportunity to go back and
visit Iran
oh it was after I had a chance to work
at NASA and it sold my first company and
got a chance to go back and visit Xander
in the village where I was born and it
was a wild experience because I got a
chance to sit down with a lot of the
kids that I used to play with when I was
four and now of course we're adults and
they're they're amazing people are just
so so much heart and there's so much fun
seeing everybody and after so many years
but it also was a real experience
because many of the people I sat down
with were illiterate and there were
sheep herders and goat herders and
a number of them spent three hours
trying to convince me that the earth is
in the center of the universe so that
was like a visceral punch in the gut for
me because of the same background as all
these guys you know we have the same
genetic code and yet our lives were so
radically different and I couldn't help
but think what would have happened if we
didn't have to flee persecution if we
wound up staying what would my life of
look like at that point yeah and the
amount of these like life-changing
moments that put people into
trajectories where they do things like
end up going and working at NASA
instead of being illiterate these are
crazy that they happen around the world
we've had multiple guests on the show
that have made it very clear that these
pivotal moments have to help turn them
into who they are today and there is
some interesting things about the
philosophies potentially of people that
are just on the land also that are just
with animals that much so it's like your
worldview yes got augmented in so many
ways and and but there still has some
interesting aspects to it that we could
still even learn from yeah absolutely I
mean there's so much separation that we
see in the Western world and as much as
I love everything we create all the
science all the technology we're moving
the human species forward and yet
there's something we lose where for most
of human history for most of the hundred
thousand years we had these tribes
around us we had these extended families
we had this constantly working with the
soil being out in the Sun being part of
nature that enables to be much happier
and be able to live much more fulfilling
lives and so we see this resurgence or
this massive spike rather in anxiety and
depression and suicidal tendencies
especially amongst young people but
generally the across the population and
especially in the Western world and a
lot of people don't really know where
that comes from but when you have
society structured in a way where you
don't really have these close
relationships anymore and so many of our
relationships and I hate to
be harping on something a lot of other
people talk about but when so many of
our relationships are on Facebook and
Instagram and when we spend most of our
time indoors don't get that vitamin D
don't have our hands in the soil don't
have that interaction with people as as
we used to I mean there's a that impacts
us in different ways yeah yeah and the
resurgence of nature back into our
essence on a daily basis is now becoming
more and more evidently important all
right and let's do this you were giving
us the bit on ass and then you ended up
also saying that you sold your first
company and then how did all of the next
years trickle into your fascination with
the fourth Industrial Revolution sure
well so let me go back a little bit so
when I was 17 I was selected to do this
presentation to the deputy White House
science advisor and NASA and it was
funny because I got on stage and I
stuttered my way suanne hour-long
presentation by the time I got off stage
my clothes were soaked head to foot I
look like I just jumped in a pool
there's a pool under me a puddle rather
of just my sweat dripping off over the
hour presentation and I walked off and
my mentor at the time said Brian that
was the worst presentation I've ever
seen in my life which was shoe it was
absurdly bad but I realized at that
point that my dream at that point was to
either become the administrator of NASA
or to run a company with 40,000
engineers ultimately to have an impact
on the world I had read quite a bit when
I was in Middle School out of Stephen
Hawking he always talked about how if we
don't learn how to colonize other
planets within a hundred years we're
gonna go extinct as a human race I
thought there's a number of problems I
wanted to solve and I'd be able to do
that at the head of a large company but
after having that experience I realized
that potentially I don't have the skill
sets necessary to do that so I
catalogued all the skill sets I thought
I would need in order to become that
person and everything from being able to
speak in public
being able to persuasively share my
ideas being articulate being able to
recruit people be able to lead
organizations and then I did an object
a catalogue of my own skill sets and I
found myself completely lacking and so
at that point I had a choice to make do
I reduce my goals fairly substantially
or do I increase my skill sets and I had
read the studies about the 10,000 hour
rule my father is a brilliant man he was
a ecology professor I used to enjoy
taking his textbooks and reading them
even when I was a kid and so I had read
about these studies and so I went after
the the original research that was done
and so this is way before malcolm
gladwell popularized this idea and I
realized hey this is something I can
actually learn the 10,000 hours I just
have to put in that kind of practice and
so in college after working at the Space
Systems lapse for for a couple of years
I decided to start a company under the
auspices of an organization called the
southwestern company which is 150 year
old company based out of Nashville
Tennessee where they teach college
students to run their own businesses
during the summer time and so I created
a company selling educational products
to families in their homes eventually I
had 72 people under me and we did a
million dollars in annual recurring
revenue and all that stuff but it was
funny because when I first started you
know and you're Armenian so you
understand the the Middle Eastern
mindset the way my I was raised as a
Persian there's a definite hierarchy of
things that you can do in life and so
doctor engineer lawyer then a whole
bunch of other things then trashman and
then underneath that even though I was
running this company I was in charge of
of course the sales and marketing but
also you know the PR and the accounting
and the logistics and all the different
elements
I remember conversations just my family
they were just like what are you doing
you left NASA to sell things to people
but at the end of the day what was
fascinating is I had a chance to sit
down with 30,000 families in their
living rooms to talk to them about their
education for their children their hopes
and dreams that challenges they faced in
Texas in Oklahoma
Ohio Wisconsin Mississippi Missouri all
over the place
and what are the things I found is that
this inequality to access the education
and opportunity exists within the United
States as well and of course more
globally and I realized that there is a
massive misalignment in terms of how
education is consumed and how its
provided what we're providing proof it
wasn't software there were educational
books the physical book there's physical
books that helped with homework they
helped us homework yeah in like middle
high school yeah elementary school
middle school high school it turns out
that most parents can't actually help
their kids with homework because math
was taught in a different way when they
were in school you know twenty thirty
years have passes they were studied
algebra and the quadratic equation so
parents really struggle to be able to
help their kids with homework and so we
would go in and provide them the
resources they needed to be able to do
well and go to college and so forth okay
and so so I stopped doing that I built a
consulting company after seven years of
building this organization seven years
for building the educational yeah
absolutely
and so that I built a consulting company
Road go into small to mid-sized
businesses and in Western North Carolina
where I lived at the time and it would
help them massively increase their
revenue I would transform the way they
managed their sales teams and their
organizations and so forth and after I
sold that is what I really started
looking at how can I change the world
and so I worked at ZocDoc for awhile I
was part of the team that took ZocDoc I
was a manager but it was helping kind of
revamp their entire sales process to a
sales 3.0 model they got to unicorn
status I then took that transition and
was the head of sales VP of Sales at a
series of tech companies that wound up
having exits or became profitable and so
at that point I realized the last
company I was working with it was a
company that used a I to automate and
personalized marketing messages and I
realized there's so much more that you
can do with artificial intelligence
rather than just use it for marketing
and to make really well I really think a
college degree is the best way to
measure how many educated people we have
but it's a it's a relatively good stand
in if we can 10x that number that's 10x
the number of engineers and doctors and
medical profession
and philosophers and scientists and
researchers we can solve a lot more of
the problems that we're facing with
education but the challenge is that
education really hasn't changed in the
past five hundred years right if you
look at transportation 500 years ago and
how its radically different if you look
at the way we consume media from 500
years ago to now it's radically
different the way we live is radically
different even the clothes we wear is
radically different but if you look at
education it's still a classroom with a
teacher in front of the class teaching
with a one-size-fits-all approach to 30
students now we've added iPads into the
classrooms and smart boards instead of
chalkboards but fundamentally it hasn't
really shifted and it's still this this
old system that eventually was designed
to Train factory workers right which is
why we have this over reliance on bells
and responding to Authority and so forth
and that just doesn't work for the
current world because right now - this
is a very long way of answering the
question that you asked we're now
weirder the precipice of what I think is
a slow-moving train wreck we're in well
into the fourth Industrial Revolution
now the first three we they were
fantastic where they worked really well
for us we had several generations for
people to be retrained for the jobs that
they needed to get into right and when
the farmers were terrified hey what
happens when all the jobs go away they
were able to over several generations to
train their kids and their kids kids to
then start learning the skill sets
necessary for other jobs the challenge
now and the reason I think it's
something we need to solve immediately
is that over the next five to ten years
and we're going to lose somewhere around
forty nine million jobs here in the
United States or I'm eight hundred
million to two billion jobs globally
depending on who you listen to whether
it's McKinsey or PwC or Gartner and so
we're in a situation where 38% of the
jobs that exist are going to be replaced
by automation and artificial
intelligence everything from truck
drivers way to uber drivers and taxi
drivers to
retail employees to fast-food workers to
phone call operators form center
operators there's a number of jobs and
then there's the jobs that rely on these
industries that we're talking about so
even to retail for example there's
different forms of retailers the Amazon
retail stores that are replacing the
workers other they need where there's
McDonald's is replacing all of their
cashiers with kiosks by 2020 but then if
you think about just the trucking
there's 3.5 million truckers in the
United States there are all sorts of
towns that have sprung up that provide
gasoline and food and services and so
forth to truckers as they make their
journeys across the country what happens
when suddenly those people don't need
any of the services anymore and so all
the cars and all the trucks are
self-driving and they don't need to stop
anymore suddenly you have all these
communities around the United States
whose means of livelihood immediately go
away what happens to those communities
do they have to immediately move to the
big cities pull the kids out of school
rip apart the social fabric of those
communities what happens to all the they
move to the metropolis is where there is
job opportunities retraining where
there's in Manhattan there's barely any
trees outside of Central Park
disconnection from nature okay further
programming with 5g and all this other
kind of stuff
yeah potentially could be the big could
be the one of the big things how do you
help the people that are in that part of
the world that are going through that
process and what is the future of
educating and helping them
well the good news is there's a solution
right because there's a number of jobs
that you can do remotely where you can
actually maintain the cohesion within
those communities where people can
retrain for the jobs of the future the
challenge is that the cohorts of people
were talking about with that first the
level of job displacement are the folks
who didn't go to college they barely
made it through high school they haven't
really up skilled at all since they left
high school they have a favorite bar
they'll go to a dog you cat two kids and
a white picket fence
right and so the traditional forms of
educating these people has already
failed in the past so there's no reason
to believe that it's going to be
successful a second time around
and so you need a different approach now
everything we interact with in our daily
lives is not personalized to us right
whether it's our Facebook feeds our
Amazon recommendation engine or the
shows we watch on Netflix everything is
custom to us even our suits right and
yet education is still a
one-size-fits-all approach even MOOCs
massive online open course ware which
was supposed to solve this problem of
scale is still a one-size-fits-all
approach that just doesn't work for most
people works for a certain subset of the
population that learns in that
particular way but it turns out I'm sure
we talked about the Blum study earlier
this is a study from 1984 that shows
that when you compare people who learn
through a private tutor or a private
instructor one-on-one 90 percent of
those students score in the top 20th
percentile when you compare them against
the entire population of students I mean
first of all Mathematica doesn't accept
having 90 percent school in the top 20
percent so was it a group that is now
subset of a much larger group and what
that tells me is you know if you take
out the bottom 10% right so that Delta
is that 70% of the population that could
be scoring much higher but is it and so
my response to that is well it's all
those students that are failing it's
that the education system is failing to
deliver that content to them in a way
that's optimized for them to be able to
understand yeah around the world and
filling the time of the fourth
Industrial Revolution when we need the
the education to be spread wide and yeah
in in in ways that are relatable for
every single one of the young people so
then yeah so let's talk about that so
how does how do we scale like a
one-on-one mentorship that gets people
trained on fourth Industrial Revolution
well that's exactly why I dedicated my
life to building a Hurra so that's a
question we asked how do we solve this
problem and so forth after I left my
position is executive making a ton of
money and saying hey I'm going to just
put my my money behind this I'm gonna
put my life behind this and I'm gonna go
for it the first three months all we did
is research to say okay what is all the
evidence out there where are all the
studies all the PhDs and I have several
of them on my advisory board but how can
we use artificial intelligence to solve
this problem and it turns out that the
optimal way for let's say Alan to learn
something is actually different at 8:00
a.m. versus 8:00 p.m. this idea that
there's visual learners or auditory
learners kinesthetic learners and that's
just the primary way you learn is
actually completely bunk because you're
not one thing depending on how much
sleep you have your nutrition your
activity level and even if you just had
a fight with one of your friends your
significant other or what have you
those all impact the optimal way that
you can actually absorb information yeah
so then the question was how do we
figure out what is your particular
mindset in that moment now there's a lot
of different ways you can do it right
there's a ton of sensors out there you
could do EEG machines that you wear that
are fairly expensive there's the number
of sensors over the past couple years
have proliferated I mean it's just
exploded exponentially but then the
problem is if you're talking about Joe
Schmo who's a 49 year old trucker out in
Sheboygan Wisconsin well is he gonna
have access to all this expensive
technology so we thought okay what is
the technology that everybody has access
to and what are the sensors that we can
use and what are the data points that we
can extract from the sensors so we
decided everybody has a laptop in this
day and age you can buy a fairly
advanced one for 200 bucks and every
laptop has a
really good camera a fairly good
microphone and so we delved into what
are all the biometric markers that we
can capture and it turns to hell you can
actually catch and recapture about
10,000 biometric data points every
second on an individual while they're on
our platform studying now of course it
brings up a lot of privacy concerns were
adamant that we're not going to use any
of this data outside of education and no
human being looks at any of the data
only the AI does and only to enable
people to learn faster but putting that
aside for the second and of course
massive levels of encryption and
security but like things like the
front-facing camera sees like my eye
movement and it's like I'm distracted
instead of focused
that's absolutely right so it captures
everything your eye tracking to your
facial expressions and micro-expressions
as well something we call a fidget score
so how much you move around while you're
looking or studying right now we're also
focusing on finding ways to capture
pupil dilation and facial flushing from
the existing cameras there's number of
different ways to do that we turn on the
microphone as well
so from voice commands and from the
various interactions we capture
sentiment analysis how you feel and how
you're acting based on your tone of
voice we use speech attacks of natural
language processing to understand the
specific word usage as well as ambient
noise we also capture you know other
pages that you go to we're also working
on adding wearables for everybody that
read the mary meeker report you know
that number of wearables in the United
States has doubled over the past year is
going to continue exponentially
increasing and so even though the it's
not as proliferated as we'd like
eventually is going to get there and so
we can capture heart rate stress rate
activity level sleep patterns from other
wearables from Apple watch or Fitbit or
you know the aura ring and other things
as well and so from that massive data
set we can understand in real time how
to share the right content to the right
person in the right format at the right
time and we can switch dynamically
between forms of contact at the
appropriate time to increase engagement
to increase outcomes and enable people
to learn much more effectively so if I
do
something like coding or designing or
architecting or whatever it is that then
I am also having my not only wearable
data but also camera data microphone
data all these things be processed so I
I do have to then enable a her a while
I'm using like a another software suite
like if I'm editing video and premiere I
just enable it her and then it watches
me as I as I do premiered yeah like yeah
that's exactly it sacktual II a very
easy plug-in that you can enable at any
point or you can have it be automatic as
well and add it to an LMS system a
learning management system or a part of
the our LMS that we've built as well for
the people that yeah okay okay so when
I'm when I'm going through a process of
yeah learning across one of the many
platforms or your platform that were
even just working that then I can turn
it on and and then it the there's also a
process of seeing my level of interest
in the material that I'm learning and
then tailoring meet the difficulty of
the material so it's my cognitive
capabilities yeah because I might be
sleep-deprived or might not have eaten
or whatever all these variables we were
talking about earlier absolutely
so it's adaptive learning and every
sense of the world both in terms of the
difficulty level but a bigger component
of that because that's been done we
added it that's not that new a lot of
adaptive learning from a perspective of
questions harder and easier questions on
the standard access as well as relaxing
the level of difficulty that's something
that is useful what we think is even
more useful is having a catalog of
dozens of different formats to teach the
exact same thing that you're learning so
not only being able to switch from let's
say text-based or experiential or video
but even within let's say video so I
don't know if you've ever been in a
situation where you're trying to listen
to someone speak but because of visual
noise or whether it's a tempo of their
voice or the particular stories they
tell or their accent
it causes distractions you can you focus
more on those verbal tics maybe
then the contents and so there's ways to
also switch the video to make it easier
to download that information now what's
really fascinating is there's two things
that I was blown away by it's a little
slightly creepy if it's used the wrong
way and so I'm super focused on not
creating a dystopian future the wrong
way but we can now rahera with a sixty
percent confidence interval predicts 10
seconds before someone pulls out their
phone mm-hmm and goes on Facebook or
Instagram because they really need that
dopamine hit we cannot predict that
they're going to do that 10 seconds
beforehand so then now we're working on
how do you increase that confidence
interval and how do you build in
interventions because you know I both
know that contacts switching costs are
extremely high every time you stop doing
what you're doing and get out of that
flow state and go on Facebook and look
at how many comments or likes the post
ads by the time you get back to work not
only have you lost that time but it
takes 25 to 45 minutes for you to be in
that flow state again with your neurons
are firing in the same way to be able to
carry on and so that's a massive time
savings huge yeah that yeah that I'm so
interested in in interventions for
keeping people in flow states that's a
really really big one we a lot of times
we think we're in control of our you
know food habits but our gut microbiome
a so I should do it there we think we're
in control of our technology but really
those notifications in many ways are in
control or what shows up in the newsfeed
these types of things so to be able to
really take full control of our
attention and our education so let's
talk about spreading this around the
world so I'm one of the other SDG for
education STG ten inequality yep that's
the second big one that we're focused on
because and I think I'm a perfect
example of this when you provide access
to educational resources and enables
people to be able to pull themselves up
it enables people to have radically
different lives and if you have access
to the same educational context in a
village in Namibia as you would if
you're living in New York suddenly those
people don't need to leave
you can get all the education that you
need and then stay and provide resources
and provide your mental talents to that
community because the thing I always
think about is what would have happened
if Einstein was born in a Syrian refugee
camp and wasn't able to leave right what
if Marie Curie was born in a tiny
village in Thailand and never had an
opportunity to leave and you know was a
rice farmer or something else and so
it's a I wonder how many brilliant
people whose capabilities we're not
using around the world and so inequality
I think is a function of that of having
access and so at a hurry what we do is
for every seat that we sell to
corporations and to universities we
provide a free seat to members of
underserved communities and we do this
in collaboration with NGOs and refugee
camps and others to make sure we're
providing those resources in the right
places yeah yeah yeah those models are a
huge part of our future yeah being able
to give and the mission align companies
end up also attracting better talent and
attract more people on to onboard them
for the project it's good okay so so
then people from around the world are
able to get a free seat as well for her
okay and then what is the is the LMS
currently that you have like a decent
amount of like modules for people to to
become educated in as well or yeah so
what we're launching the beta version in
about four to five months we have an
alpha version that's live we have a
bunch of people on it with the beta
version yeah we'll have five different
set of courses we already have most of
the content for that from a whole bunch
of different sources that we have
partnerships with it's like a Spotify
type model which is kind of cool but so
they're social media management coding
with Java and Python therapy and finance
and I use the coding as two of them
because there's are two different sets
of classes so when we decided on which
horses we would start off with I wanted
to make sure that number one their jobs
that they could do from anywhere you
could do remote work number two that
have
a college degree in that area was it
really needed and that employers don't
really care about whether you have a
college you really care more about you
actually being able to perform the work
and know the contract and number three
then being areas where there's a massive
misalignment between supply and demand
so there's a lot more demand for those
jobs than there is supply so if we use
social media as an example every massive
corporation needs an army of social
media managers that create their social
media strategy and execute on it and
yeah there aren't enough people that are
capable in doing that and so you see
that I've had so many conversations with
presidents of universities that have
told me hey Brian we have we put our
instructional designers and have them
spend two years build out an entire
curriculum on how to become a social
media manager so we can teach our
students but by the time that course is
ready to roll out
it's completely and utterly obsolete
right and so most of the social media
managers now are fairly self taught you
you know their practice and so forth but
what winds up happening I have so many
friends that are global citizens and
digital nomads or do the VAM life thing
right and travel around an event spend
several hours today running a social
media for these massive corporations and
the fact that corporations are in such a
poor bargaining position where they have
to accept that these people are just not
gonna come into the office and they'll
probably put in a couple hours a day and
they don't really have that much
oversight it's because those are the
only people that know how to do the work
there aren't enough people for them to
have a good negotiating position this is
massive supply demand misalignment and
we can train people to do that that's
fantastic because going back to that you
know trucker or a you know coal miner or
the person who in retail for the past 20
years this is something that they can
very easily learn if it's taught to them
the right way and instead of having to
take their kids out of school and rip
apart the social fabric they can do that
job right from home they don't have to
move to New York with our lack of trees
yeah yeah this is the huge upswing in
new jobs that are also created and also
potentially jobs that people
can stay in their local communities and
continue doing and learn from yeah all
the all the fields that we were talking
about earlier it's it's gonna be a
challenge to see how to fit people that
are losing jobs that they're currently
know how to do in their later years of
their life when they don't have as much
neuroplasticity to do things like pickup
how to learn a RvR learn how to do IOT
stuff blockchain stuff it's much harder
but it it's it's possible I mean yeah
social media management's I think easier
than unity programming right these types
of things sure maybe no I'm not talking
about teaching these guys how to do well
my friend calls a rocket surgery right
we don't need to teach them how to be
blockchain programmers that's fairly
hard even for most programmers but let
me give you another example so there's
this massive changes happening in our
society where there's these spikes in
anxiety and depression and suicidal
tendencies not only most young people
but across the population more generally
and so there's these new apps that are
rising I'm sure you've heard of them
where basically uber for therapy because
it turns out that most of the middle
class and lower class don't have 300 to
400 dollars an hour to put aside for
therapists that have PhDs and master's
degrees and so they wind up just not
going because it's a matter of do I put
my kid in this therapy for $300 an hour
and not pay rents well who do I pay
grants and that's a fairly easy answer
for most most people so what's turning
up is these uber like apps where people
can pay a complete stranger 25 to 50
dollars an hour to listen to their
problems and they know that this person
doesn't know any of their people they're
not going to talk to their friends and
tell them their secrets and there they
have a basic level of training where
they can ask the right questions and
provide a listening ear just like we
have suicide hotlines right there's the
people on the other end of the suicide
hotline don't have master's degree in
therapy or a PhD in psychotherapy on
demand massages will be an interesting
one yeah that's exactly right so you can
train people on these kind of skill sets
and enable them to do meaningful work
that they connect with and it doesn't
have to be blockchain or data science or
training people to become AI programmers
some of these things are more
complicated there are a lot more
difficult once that neuroplasticity
starts to go away in the later years and
so that's definitely something that
we've been thinking about for sure and
then how about you know it's making a
lot of sense with artificial
intelligence in education I think it's
yeah like you said probably I think
education and poverty are the two big
ones that if you can if we can really
target those and figure them out all the
other ones can more easily get tackled
and solved by a lot of other of the
young people around the world but then
where does this lead to all these new
fourth Industrial Revolution
technologies being birthed into the
world a lot of people are really
concerned about some of the biotech
neuro tech being unleashed for just
people that have financial resources
that can afford them other people say
don't worry don't worry it'll be
democratized over time everyone will get
access to it so where do you stand on
the inequality with the fourth
Industrial Revolution that's uh
something I'm definitely very concerned
about because look the the work that's
being done right now on both genetic
modification with CRISPR and other
technologies as well as biohacking
as well as brain computer interfaces and
whether it's non-invasive
neuromodulation or invasive with actual
computer chips there's a lot of
opportunity for people that have the
resources or have the inclination
because some people just aren't willing
to do that kind of change for themselves
there's the potential for misuse right
there's a potential that a certain
subset of the population engages in this
kind of activity and gets a an
instrumental advantage over another
segment of the population whether it's
in terms of intelligence or cognitive
ability or memory or even physical
strength there's people right now that
are adding compasses into their by
health a G and connecting and this is
stuff that you can do fairly easily if
you look it up I mean anybody can go do
it now and so that's just obviously the
first step but what happens when you
have a segment of the popular
that does this and then is later
threatened by the rest of the population
that's decided that's not natural right
now I want to take a step back for a
second because there's some other issues
that are coming into play right because
we've been talking about the truck
drivers and retail employees that are
gonna lose their jobs the the repetitive
manual labor that's going to be replaced
what a lot of people don't realize and I
talked to a lot of very intelligent very
educated people that say oh that could
never happen to me I'm an accountant
I'm a lawyer I'm a programmer and it
turns out that these repetitive
cognitive tasks will also be replaced it
just won't be the next five to ten years
will be ten to twenty years down the
road where radiology there's already a
ton of research that's happening that
some companies are doing this where a I
can do radiology better than human
doctors many accountants many lawyers
many programmers will also be replaced
down the road and so you're talking
about a wholesale change in the way the
society functions number one number two
we have this societal construct that you
and I and probably most of our viewers
were raised in which you go to school
for either 12 or 16 or 20 or more years
depending on what you choose to do then
in a linear progression you work for 30
or 40 years and then you retire that's
the world that we were given that's what
we've done for a pretty long time and
what we're seeing now is that's changing
because of the rapid pace at which
entire industries are rising and then
dying the rapid pace of them for the
need for rapidly upskilling and
rescaling for future what you're seeing
is that the future is going to look
quite different where instead of having
this linear progression we're going to
have a need for lifelong learning to
continually upscale and rescale lifelong
work potentially in multiple jobs
simultaneously what people call a
portfolio career and lifelong leisure so
instead of waiting for retirement
plugging that in for healthy lifestyles
and having a balanced balanced life and
so that's a fundamentally different way
of living then we have done the past and
so we're gonna have to address that
right hopefully giving everyone that
ability to do the lifelong learning and
lifelong leisure and lifelong work doing
things that they love doing things that
are part of the fourth Industrial
Revolution or being able to connect to
nature more along the journey and how do
we do that how do we ensure that every
human is able to pursue their North Star
with great vigor well at the end of the
day I think it comes down to education
which is why I've dedicated my life to
it I think it comes down to having for
example an AI that follows you
throughout your whole life and knows you
better than you know yourself but
instead of using that AI to sell you
things that you don't need or spend more
time flicking through an endless
newsfeed having that AI be able to
understand in any given time how to
teach you so that down the road in
addition to learning how to be am a
social media manager for example when
you buy a dog and you want to learn how
to house train it you can immediately
say okay what's the fastest way that I
can learn this material based on all the
content that exists or you have a child
and you're looking here well how do I
raise a healthy child how do I learn all
of the information how do i download it
and we all have this dream any of us
that saw the matrix right I'm just
plugging in and just downloading the
information and obviously the science
fiction we can't do that until Elon or
Brian Johnson succeeds and you know
putting a implant in every one of our
brains but before we get to that point
how do you learn all that material how
do you learn empathy how do you learn
how to engage with Screwjob you learn
how to speak in public without doing it
the old-fashioned way so AI agents that
are democratized that help us with our
education on a moment-to-moment basis
towards what direction we want to pursue
in general maybe also monitoring
biometrics to know exactly how we feel
in those states all this type of stuff
well that's part of the reason I'm so
excited about IOT and 5g really starting
to come out because as a sensor has
become more ubiquitous and as they
achieve larger market penetration as you
have sensors in your tell them in your
television and in your refrigerator and
bad and as we have even more data than
we can tweak the algorithms and become
more more effective at being able to
understand how to optimize a lot this is
probably a good point then to insert
well okay out of all of these you know
fourth Industrial Revolution
technologies it seems as though they're
also enabling the potential for
malevolence to come through more easily
so what do you think is evil and how do
you think it can be avoided in the
fourth Industrial Revolution you know
that's a really good question right and
at the end of the day I'm not a
philosopher and I'm not a spiritual
leader so take anything I say with a
grain of salt or an entire salt shaker
fool but I think evil is the intentional
causing of suffering or pain and another
individual and we see people do this
right they they realize that their
actions are going to cause pain in other
people but they make a calculation I
guess in their mind that the benefit
that they sustain is worthwhile the pain
they caused to others and I don't know
how to solve that I think through
education potentially you can teach
children from a much younger age empathy
and how to come to the spiritual
realization realization that we're all
actually part of the same or super
organism that you and I are different
iterations of essentially the same being
I mean it's like this idea of if you had
a blood cell a red blood cell and your
body that decided hey screw everybody
else I'm my own person I'm not connected
to any of the other tissue and just
begins attacking everything else well we
have a name for that we call that cancer
but when humans do that we sometimes
have other names for it whether it's
selfishness or or other things that I'm
not going to say on the podcast that do
you you feel like part of the
disconnection from spirit or source what
sustains us nature the ecosystem is on
this planet do you feel like that
disconnection has caused room for evil
to be more prevalent well potentially I
feel like and I'm not a historian but
from everything I've read I think he
evil is existed long before we moved
from an agrarian society internet
industrial one and far before we wants
online the challenge I think now is it's
a lot more visible which causes people
to focus on it more on them that could
be good or bad right if you look at the
the data from almost all metrics the
world is moving in a positive direction
right there's fewer Wars there's fewer
fatalities as fewer there's less crime
there's less poverty there's less infant
mortality the world is actually going in
a really good direction it's it's pretty
incredible how far we've come in the
short period of time now with that being
said because we're all interconnected
and because of the technological
advancements that we've had a few bad
actors can have a much more profound
effect on a large number of people and
so the the power of people who perhaps
with lack of conscious conscience or are
sociopaths or are willing to perform
evil acts on other people they're more
enabled to act in ways that do not
benefit humanity but rather benefit a
very small number of people and we see
that in the environment right there's a
recent study that shows that there's
about a hundred people in the world that
are causing 90% of global warming and
the catastrophic climate change and so
well what do we do about that yeah deep
spiritual enlightenment about the
ecosystems that sustain us and prevent
the dynamics that enable people to
pollute the environment which has no say
and what people decide to do with with
things then something and self-dealing
tendencies these things I think of yeah
evolving away from them of course how
about we go into simulation through
sure absolutely do you think we're in a
simulation absolutely I mean I think
it's I don't know the answer but I think
from a statistical perspective it's very
highly likely that we're in a simulation
I mean I don't need to go through this
statistics with you I'm sure you and all
your viewers already have seen it well I
will look at is from a scientific
perspective if you were creating a
simulation where you wanted the AI in
the simulation to not realize it's a
simulation what are some things you
would do and I think I stole this from
maybe an xkcd comic or something but
you're essentially set the parameters of
the physical environment such that they
can't actually see the limits right you
would create a universe that's expanding
faster than the speed of light and it
makes the speed of light and absolute
maximum speed and so there's no way to
actually see the edges of of the
simulation right it's really interesting
when you get into quantum mechanics and
you look at the way that particles
behave at a subatomic level whether
they're particles or waves and you
probably know the shorter here's cat
analogy it's really fascinating that
with all of the experiments have been
replicated in every country if we're
looking at a subatomic particle it
either behaves as a wave or a point
depending on whether we're looking at it
or not and the universe knows if we're
looking at it if we stop looking at it
goes back to behaving as a wave as a
potentiality right but then the minute
we look it immediately solidifies and so
it's that's fascinating to me I don't
know the answer to that I don't think
anything this is the live does that was
the most challenging answer thank you
Brian absolutely it's where do you think
that leads then with our of course yes
the hard to probe the edges of the
simulation potentially purposely made so
that way but then we bake in our own
simulations and observe those and
all these types of things and then also
the where do you think that goes with
like life trajectories where you know
all the possibility states exist for
Bryan's life and then you look one way
and then you choose and collapse it the
direction of your life well it's a
really fascinating question that we can
dive into the 11 dimensions right of
going beyond the first four and their
timing the fourth one which we know is
space that's slightly different in a
different format but once we get into
the fifth and sixth dimension it looks
at all of the potential realities that
all exists at the same time very because
we know from quantum mechanics or at
least from all the theories shrink
theory and so forth that the few shorty
exist the past exists and we're just
going through this dimension time that
we don't control just like a two
dimensional being living in the
three-dimensional world can observe the
third dimension they can measure the
third dimension but can never actually
control the third dimension and travel
within it right and so if we're looking
at it from that lens there's a future
Brian that's a trashman there's a future
Brian that's a billionaire there's a
future Brian that is a saint and there's
a future Brian that's in prison and so
all of those futures also exist
simultaneously that the question is this
iteration of Brian which future do I
wind up experiencing and living and
there's other iteration other iterations
that will experience the other ones and
so that's going to be the parallel
universes experiencing those that's
exactly right and so then the question
is all the decisions we make day-to-day
and it's generally in my experience that
could be completely wrong it's not one
or two big decisions that create the
trajectory of our lives it's a series of
small decisions that we make continually
over time yeah that wind up having an
impact on which of these future
potentials that we live into and so we
see them collapse as we look at them as
we pay attention to them into the one
the one feature and so that's a question
I wake up with every day I asked myself
well first of all I start by journaling
my gratitude because I found that to be
very useful for me yeah I think about
all the things I'm grateful for but I
think about and I have a painting of
myself that we did through here or glass
represents the idealized version of me
that created by an AI for 20 years from
now so I can look at and say okay that
Brian that has already lived into this
reality what decisions would he make
today what is he doing to leave the
world in a better place than I found it
and so I think that's a question that at
times in my life when I haven't asked
and I've gone into that just that rote
life that habit patterns that we create
sometimes you forget about that just get
lost into the day-to-day and I wake up
and it feels like six months later it's
like holy cow what did I actually do
over the past six months that I'd do
anything to make the world a better
place or that I just stack some cash and
do some work that didn't really matter
and so I try and I'm not perfect at it
but one of the things that I focus on is
trying to to make that at the forefront
of my mind every morning yeah yeah and
that's what you do with Hiro glass again
links to the bio is again this ideal
self when you future author yourself in
this state of achieving your North Star
and you know your incremental steps that
you need to get there this type of thing
that can really launch someone off
versus not knowing not journaling not
having gratitude not this type of stuff
so just completely different like true
life trajectories with even simple
things like that what do you think
happens before birth and after death
that's a really good question alright so
that's a question of at the end of the
day is our consciousness a local or a
non-local
phenomena so I think every philosopher
has asked this question of is our
consciousness a function of our brain
and our biome or is this body just a
vehicle for a consciousness that exists
beyond space and time or beyond our
lifecycle so I would look at this in two
ways so one thing I would say is I used
to be an atheist and after coming across
simulation hypothesis and really diving
into it and I realized I can't be an
atheist then I moved to agnostic because
that I they could be a this could all be
a seventh-grade homework assignments
where the kid get a see right that's
just as possible is the god hypothesis
everything else but if we're looking at
consciousness all of the evidence that
I've seen where maybe I should say I
haven't seen any evidence to suggest
that our consciousness is non-local or
that our consciousness exists after we
die I am open to being proven wrong
during my like it's all consciousness my
I I think it's a function I personally
believe that many animals are conscious
that we just don't know it because they
have no way of communicating those ideas
to us right my working hypothesis is on
this is that our consciousness is
actually quite primitive compared to
what I can be because so much of our
behavior is actually just operant
conditioning and classical conditioning
so much of the behavior that we have so
much of the ways that we think about
life we think that we have free will but
really we're just following a path based
on all the experiences that we've had
all the interactions we've had with
people all the books that we've read
that have molded our realities and so
the question then in my mind is if I had
been born in your body and I had lived
through all your experiences what I
behave in the exact same way as you and
I think there's a certain fatalism to
that but at the same time I think it's
likely but then that brings up the
question of what happens when we
download our brain into a robot so or if
we download our brain into another body
for example on a Ray Kurzweil famously
once the download has been into a
computer and so forth so is that a
transference of memories is that what
makes us who we are is it a transference
of the actual let's say soul or
consciousness I don't know the answer to
that but I suspect that it's it's local
and then what do you think is the most
beautiful thing in the world the most
beautiful thing in the world
other than you of course I think I think
it's a joy pure unbridled joy when you
see a person that's just overcome with
that happiness that they can't contain
it's I think an incredibly beautiful
thing yeah it's a good on yeah makes me
feel warm happy he's new reminds me of
the ride back up from the last weekend
with Mama I was really excited yeah yeah
I was really excited yeah yeah those
moments are so precious yeah and to be
able to help make them more available
for all humans again I think it has so
much to do with just our connection to
nature that can bring us that joy yeah
yeah in the film we watch today the 12
yeah yeah that was amazing and I mean I
think it you're absolutely right I think
nature plays a really large role and
being connected to the world and I think
part of it too is at least for me when
I'm engaged with something that it fully
deeply believed in that's completely
aligned with my values in my life and I
feel like I'm having an impact out you
know what it's like for other people but
I suspect there's some elements that
that are the same that when you feel
like you're doing the right thing that
you're you're going after your calling I
feel like that can create that joy for
you as well at least it does for me
anywhere it ceases to be about the
material possessions and you lose
yourself in the work because it just
brings you this feeling of true
fulfillment yes yeah again just if you
feel so happy and every human deserves
exactly that pursuing their North Star
with full vigor yeah yeah
we'll joy long the way Brian thank you
very much for coming on the show thank
you for having you this has been an
amazing conversation thank you yeah a
lot of fun yes they're coming on and
teaching us about all this go to blast
you should thank you to everyone for
tuning in we greatly appreciate it love
to hear your thoughts in the comments
below on the episode also check out the
links in the bio below again that's a
hurrah a i.com
also hero glass org and all of the
social profiles so Brian check those out
everyone and also go and share more
content around AI and education have
more conversation to your family your
friends co-workers people online on
social media about things like the SDGs
about the fourth Industrial Revolution
about the ways to minimize inequality in
the future all these types of things and
shout out to Ron Vargas for producing
and directing thank you very much Ronnie
and also support the artists
entrepreneurs the organizations around
the world that you believe and support
them help them grow support simulation
our links are below patreon
cryptocurrency and paypal support us and
if you want to design merch and get paid
that link is below as well go and build
the future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world you love you very much
like you for tuning in we'll see you
soon peace